المنزل الذي استهدفته قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي بالطائرات الحربيه واحدثت
دمارا واسعا في
المكان ايش اللي صار عندكم مجدره اي صارت
مجدره مجدره من كل البلد صارت
مجدره بجي 30 واحد ف خمس ست عيال مح على
الوجود تبع عيال المح على الوجود هم
واولادهم ونسوانهم ولا واحد ضيل منهم ولسه
ما طلنا يمكن منهم ع والباقي كلهم ه تحت
لس ه تصور شوف شوفوا هي شايف هذه يد طفل
صغير كما تشاهدونها الان تحت الانقاض وهذا
يعتقد انه والده بجواره كما تشاهدون الان
في هذه تحت الانقاض لاستهداف منزل عائله
خله مش قادرين نطلعهم صرنا ندفنهم تحت
الانقاض نحط حجار عليهم ه زي ما انت شايف
غطينا مش قادرين لا في مقبره نصلها ولا في
مكان نن مش قادرين تنت شلوهم المقبره
نفسها ضربوا الناس وهم يدفنوا يا عم
المقبره منعوها ندفن فيها هينا بغطيه زي
ما انت شايف يا نغطيهم بنحط الحجار فوقيهم
فوق يعني هذه القذفه سقطت على على الاهالي
اثناء انتشالهم جثامين الشهداء كما
تشاهدونها الان القذيفه لم تنفجر بشكل
كامل هذا الشارع تدمر بالكامل هذا الحي
بالكامل تم تدميره بهذا البرميل كما
يسميها المواطنين او الس الفتاك الذي سقط
على رؤوس المدنيين في هذه المنطقه كما
تشاهدون اينما تضع عينك هناك دمارا واسعا
في هذه
المنطقه جمين الشهداء كما تشاهدون في
مقبره جماعيه هنا جثامين الشهداء كم شهيد
في
هنادي 60 نفر تحت الضار تح ال يعني اكثر
من 60 شهيدا تحت الانقاض وهؤلاء عدد من
الشهداء الذين تم انتشالهم كما تشاهدون في
هذه المقبره الجماعيه التي
التي اعدها في نفس المكان الذي استشهدوا
به كما تشاهدون
الان هنا يصلون على
الشهداء قبل ان يضعوا الرمال على قب على
قبرهم الجماعي